في كل مكان يوجد سباق للحصول على لقاح مغطى
ولكن هنا في لندن بادينجتون
هناك سباق لنوع جديد من اللقاح
تمامًا
الأستاذة روبن تقود فريقًا في
إمبريال كوليدج يستخدم تقنية جديدة
لجعل جسم الإنسان
يتعرف على الجزء الأكثر خطورة  من
الفيروس الخطاف أو السنبلة من الخارج
حتى يكون الجسم جاهزًا إذا رأى
الشيء الحقيقي في أي وقت ، ولا حتى إعطاء
جزء من الفيروس من الجسم ، فأنت تعطي
الجسم خططًا للجزء الأكثر فتكًا
من الفيروس على
الإطلاق  ابدأ التجارب البشرية في منتصف يونيو ،
وأتمنى إجراء ستة آلاف اختبار على البشر بحلول
أكتوبر ، وربما في أوائل العام المقبل ،
ستكون هذه التقنية الثورية
جاهزة لك أو إليكم كيف تعمل
النتوءات على سطح الفيروس ، وهو
ما يسمح له بالهجوم والحصول على
في الخلايا في جسمك ، تقوم تقنيتهم
ن الشفرة الجينية لتلك السنبلة في
لجسم وتسمح لخلايا عضلاتك بإ
داث الكثير من النتوءات ويتعرف جهاز المناعة على ذل
ويبدأ في صن
مضادات الأجسام المضادة.  يموت الذي يربط ويتعرف على
هذا الارتفاع حتى أنه عندما ترى أن
الفيروس بأكمله
قد تم تحصينه ، فإن جهازك
المناعي يصنع أجسامًا مضادة على المستوى الإقليمي مما
يعني
أن الفيروس لم يعد قادرًا على إصابة الخلايا ، فهذه
تقنية جديدة تمامًا لأن معظم
اللقاحات تعطي  إضعاف الفيروس
بأكمله للجسم لتعلم محاربة
الخلايا تعمل كمصنع
يصنعون اللقاح بأنفسهم يقومون
برفع الأشياء الثقيلة بدلاً من الاضطرار إلى
صنع كميات هائلة من الفيروس في نبات الرجل
وهذه التقنية لها ميزتان هما
الكميات  هناك حاجة ماسة لكل جرعة
صغيرة جدًا وحتى 16000 لتر من
الناحية النظرية يقولون إنها كافية
لتطعيم العالم بأسره ولتقنية إذا
نجحت في استخدامها مع فيروسات أخرى
أيضًا في المستقبل ،
فإن الخطوات الضخمة لفيروس كورونا تجبرنا على أخذنا في طريقنا
إلى  عالم جديد من
التطورات العظيمة غير المتوقعة ،
مرحبًا ، أنا كزافييه هامبرغر ، أنا
طبيب التخدير في Mount Sinai ، في
يومياته بالفيديو ، وقائع شخصية
لطبيب يتقاتل  فيروس كورونا على
الخطوط الأمامية لهذا الوباء كطبيب
تخدير في فريق الاستجابة السريعة
في مستشفى Mount Sinai في مدينة نيويورك ،
إنه يرى المرضى الأكثر حرجًا
كل يوم كان علي إجراء
محادثة مع المريض
وابنها حول ما تريد  لقد أنجزت بالنسبة
لها نوع الإجراءات المتطرفة التي يمكننا
القيام بها لإبقائها على قيد الحياة
لأنه من غير الآمن على العائلات
زيارة دور الأطباء في
اللحظات الأخيرة للمريض أصبح
الشيء الوحيد الذي يمكننا القيام به
كأطباء وممرضات هو  هو محاولة وكن
شخصًا معهم حتى في النهاية
حتى لو لم تستطع أسرهم أن يكونوا هناك جسديًا
د.  أخبرنا همبرغر أنه لا يزال
أحد أصعب أجزاء علاج
مرضى COBIT ، ويقول إنه بينما
تنخفض حالات الاستشفاء والتنبيب ، هناك المئات من الأشخاص الذين
ما زالوا يموتون من kovin 19 كل يوم
في نيويورك وبعد أسابيع على الخطوط الأمامية.
لقد أثرت على كل شخص
في المستشفى الآن يتعامل مع
هذه المشاعر وهذه المشاعر كان لدينا
خريجون من برنامج التمريض
يبكون في بئر السلم لا أستطيع حتى
الوصول إليه ووضع ذراعك حول
شخص ما ولكن هذا هو الضغط
حقًا  الرعاية الصحية التي تعمل في الوقت الحالي
ليس فقط الحصول على أنفسهم ولكن
الانتشار هو د.  يقول هامبرغر إن
أطباء آخرين أخبروه أن مقاطع الفيديو هذه تساعد في
إظهار ما يمر به العاملون في مجال الرعاية الصحية
كل يوم بما في ذلك المخاطر التي
استيقظت من نومي ليلًا مع حمى وقشعريرة
في وقت ما في منتصف مارس على الرغم من جميع
احتياطاته ، إلا أنه بدأ تظهر عليه الأعراض
بعد فترة وجيزة ، وكذلك فعلت زوجته  واثنين من
أبنائه الثلاثة علينا أن
نحبسهم أنام حقًا إلى الأبد ، كان هو وعائلته
مصابين بحالات خفيفة من كوفات 19 وتعافى تمامًا
من التبرع ببلازما النقاهة ،
وهو يأمل أن ينتهي التبرع
بمساعدة الآخرين ويتطلع إلى الأمام ،
كما يقول.  الكثير من الحديث عن
إعادة الفتح والمضي قدمًا حتى لا ننسى
أولئك الذين ما زالوا يقاتلون القتال
كل يوم أعتقد أن الكثير من الناس
قلقون من أن الناس لا يبدأون في
نسياننا على
الخطوط الأمامية وعندما تتوقف الساعة السابعة
عن التصفيق و  عندما
تبدأ القصص في الشعور بالضيق
من وجودنا في الخطوط الأمامية ،
سنحتاج إلى مساعدة الناس
أكثر من غيرهم لأن هذا هو الوقت الذي سنأتي فيه
كونك مقدم رعاية صحية دائمًا ما يكون
شديد الخطورة ومليئًا بالتوتر ، لكن
الخبراء يقولون إنه بسبب فيروس كورونا ،
فإن عوامل الخطر والضغوط هذه
تضخيم يصبح عمال الرعاية الصحية لدينا
ما يسمى بالضحايا الثانية
لهذه الأزمة التي يشير هذا المصطلح إلى أولئك الذين
يعانون  الصدمة المتعلقة
برعاية المريض ، أنت تتحدث عن مجموعة
ضعيفة من الناس ، أعني
أنك تعلم أن الموت عن طريق الانتحار بين
المجتمع الطبي أعلى من
عامة السكان ، وداخل فرق
الطوارئ الطبية وعاملي الطوارئ هو الأعلى
حتى بين العاملين في المجال الطبي حتى تعرف
هناك الكثير من مستشفيات الإجهاد في
جميع أنحاء البلاد
تعمل في أو تزيد ساعات العمل عن طاقتها ،
مما أدى إلى زيادة
الإمدادات وندرة المعدات الوقائية أو
عدم وجودها في بعض الأحيان ، ومع ذلك
من المتوقع أن يقدم العاملون في مجال الرعاية الصحية
لكل مريض 110  في المائة وبسبب
مدى عدوى هذه الأمراض
لا يُسمح للمرضى في كثير من الأحيان بالتواصل
مع أحبائهم  وضع
أطبائهم وممرضاتهم في موقع
المعزي ، كما قرر الكثيرون في صناعة الرعاية الصحية
إبعاد أنفسهم عن أفراد الأسرة
للحفاظ على سلامتهم
من الخسائر النفسية الكبيرة ، وكذلك
ليس فقط لأنفسهم من حيث
أنا أنا.  هل سبق لي أن أصبت بالفيروس
الذي تعرضت له للتو ، ثم عدت إلى المنزل ومن المحتمل أن
أعرضه للآخرين ، ولهذا السبب الآن
أكثر من أي وقت مضى يحتاجون إلى دعمنا
للحظة الصحية اليوم ، أنا Mandy Gaither
you